hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast regulation of microtubule
plus end dynamics during axon guidance
and cell migration presented by dr.
Laura Lowery assistant professor of
biology at Boston College I'm Suzie
Valdez of lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots
libraries is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I'd like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation click on that green Q&A
button located at the lower left of your
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of our
presentation please also notice that you
will be viewing this presentation in a
slide window if you'd like to enlarge
that window just click on the screen
icon located on the lower right if you
have any trouble seeing or hearing this
presentation click on the support button
at the top right of your presentation
window or use that Q&A button to let us
know you're having a problem good news
this presentation is educational and
offers educational continuing credits
please click on that button in the
bottom left hand corner and follow the
process to obtain your credit without
further ado please join me in welcoming
dr. Laura Lowery oh um now turn the
presentation over to her welcome dr.
Lowery thank you very much Susie it is
such a pleasure for me to have this
opportunity to tell you about the
research that's going on in my lab I've
been an assistant professor in biology
at Boston College for about four years
now the big picture research question
that has fascinated me for as long as I
can remember it's how to cells move how
do they find their way how does this
cell move towards the right direction
whatever that may be and away from the
wrong direction now this is a
fundamental question in cell biology
cell movement happens
the embryo during development it happens
in the adult during wound healing in the
immune response and it happens
inappropriately during cancer metastasis
I want to make note that these movies
aren't going to play in this
presentation but if you want to see any
of these movies alive please feel free
to email me and I'm happy to send you
clips of them so you can watch them in
your own time so the movement is
critical in development and there can be
disastrous consequences with a variety
of pathological situations if some
movement happens inappropriately now
cell movement is particularly critical
during embryonic development embryonic
development requires both collective and
individual cell movements many different
cell types have to migrate over a
complex embryonic terrain to get to
where they need to be for proper tissue
assembly and organ formation in this
cell movement process there is a machine
inside cells that derived movement and
this machine is called the cytoskeleton
there are two critical components of the
cytoskeleton that my lab focuses on
actin filaments which drive felt shape
and cell motility and microtubules which
provides cell polarity in organization
both of these cytoskeletal systems are
critical for cell movement my lab has
been focused particularly on how the
cytoskeleton machine is regulated during
embryonic development and in
specifically in nervous system
development
I've been studying aspects of the
nervous system for about 17 years now
and within nervous and development there
are two different times at least two
different kinds of cell movement first
every neuron might be born in one
location for example the neural tube but
then have to migrate to a different
location for example a particular layer
in the brain and then once a performs
this cell migration process then each
neuron sends out an extension of itself
called an axon and sends it over long
embryonic distances to
the essential connections that wire up
the nervous system
now obviously wiring up the nervous
system with accuracy and precision is
vital to our normal physiological
functions and defects in this process
lead to a long list of
neurodevelopmental disorders including
we now think it contributes to autism
and schizophrenia in understanding how
these connections form may also allow us
to design more targeted strategies for
promoting regeneration after injury
now informing these connections the
primary player in this process is the
growth cone this is the hand-like
dynamic structure at the tip of the
growing axon it's the growth cones job
to find its targets and my lab focuses
on how it moves in the right direction
and how cells move in the right
direction
to answer these two questions my lab
uses the model system Senator Leyva's
and I thought very carefully about which
model system to use from my lab over the
last couple decades I have extensively
used C elegans I've used Drosophila as a
zebrafish I've dabbled in mouse and
chick and when I came to realize is that
there may be no other vertebrate model
system that has primary embryonic cells
as large and as easy and inexpensive to
culture manipulate an image as benefice
Lavis particularly for looking at
cytoskeletal dynamics and so since I
have a large lab with many students and
they all want to have their own embryos
every week to do their experiments
Xenopus laevis is a fantastic model
system we can collect hundreds to
thousands of eggs every week fertilize
them inject constructs 4G manipulation
dissect out the neural tube or other
cell types were interested in plate
those cells and then for example with
neurons the axons will grow out and
their large growth cones allow for clear
visualization of individual microtubules
and complexes that regulate microtubules
now when my lab
again in 2014 our primary focus was on
investigating microtubule regulators and
how they played a role during axon
guidance and a large subset of my lab
still focuses on this project but over
the last two years I've been fortunate
and that my lab has expanded in size and
scope in terms of our funded research
projects so I want to spend the first
half of this talk telling you about
microtubule regulator and axon guidance
project focusing on the key highlights
we've made the key insights and then
I'll talk about these new directions
that my lab is going in if you think
about the growth cone its primary
function is to make decisions whether to
move forward to retract or to turn the
scientists have been studying axon
guidance for over a hundred years but we
still don't understand how the ROS cones
gears in the right direction now that's
not to say that we don't know anything
we know a lot classic genetics and
molecular studies have already given us
lots of guidance cues we know receptors
that are on the growth cone we know
signaling pathways that transduce those
cues we know a lot of the molecular
players there's also been some really
beautiful descriptive biology of growth
cone cytoskeletal dynamics but what's
missing what's still missing after all
this time is the linkage between the two
the emergence of an integrated picture
of the cytoskeleton machine in the
context of its possible effectors how do
its effectors spatially and temporally
influenced cytoskeletal dynamics to
steer the growth cone in the right
direction I mentioned there are these
two critical elements of the growth cone
cytoskeleton as actin is involved in
growth cone motility and microtubules
promotes axon outgrowth but if the
growth cone is going to steer in a
directed manner these two cytoskeletal
systems have to be coordinated and one
place to look for that is where they
physically interact so there are a group
of dynamic microtubules that explore the
growth temporary and they can perform
this internal growth context
raishin by utilizing their property of
dynamic instability where microtubules
switch between growing phases and
shrinking phases and by rapidly
switching between these two states they
can effectively explore the entire
growth [ __ ] space and even probe into
these Philip Odia where guidance cues
are first detected at the tips of these
microtubules are a family of proteins
called plus and tracking proteins are
plus tips and they regulate microtubule
dynamics it's known that plus of
activity is directly modulated by
upstream kinase signaling and not only
do plus tips regulate microtubules but
also they bind to actin and structure
such as adhesions so it seems quite
plausible that plus tips might take a
central role in orchestrating the growth
cone response to guidance cues but the
details for how this might occur are
largely unknown as plastic interaction
and function in the developing nervous
system has not been extensively examined
when I was in my postdoc at Harvard
Medical School I performed dual genetic
and proteomic streams in Drosophila
which is a great screening platform to
identify new microtubule regulators that
were playing a role in the growth camp I
was very fortunate to have a successful
screen I've taken all these screen hits
to my own lab but I decided to start by
focusing on XM up to 15 and tack 3 it
was known that they directly interact
through their c-terminal domains and
these two proteins they regulate
microtubule dynamics at the mitotic
spindle and during cell division and
it's been known for over a decade that
they do this but their potential
functions within the developing nervous
systems had not been examined previously
now XM up to 15 is the best known
catalytic microtubule polymerase it
binds to tubulin dimers in the cytoplasm
as well as the plus end depositing the
tubulin dimers onto the microtubule to
grow the microtubule and it is
to this plus on localization XM up to 15
is also located at the centrosome from
where most microtubules nucleate and
it's thought that it's there so that it
can load on to new microtubules and
promote their growth this is where TAC 3
enters the scene TAC 3 was not described
as a plus tip it actually was published
in the literature that it did not bind
to microchip license tax stands for
transforming acidic oil domain and its
function was that it was a centrosome
adaptor and its main micro tubular
regulatory behavior was that it could
bind to X map to 15 and recruit X map to
the centrosome so that their ex map can
load onto microtubules so tack 3
function and regulating microtubules was
thought to be very indirect but I had a
sense that this was not actually the
case the studies which showed that
Factory was not a plus tip were had some
some experimental flaws so I wondered if
Caffrey actually could function as a
positive and does it regulate
microtubule plus and dynamics more
directly than simply recruiting X naught
to 15 two centrosomes those were the
first two questions that I decided to
start with so before I get into the
function of these regulators in axon
guidance I want to talk about my labs
initial attempts at exploring the role
of tack 3 in regulating microtubule
dynamics and this was spearheaded by the
original Lowry lab team Belinda and Anna
who were post back to the time Beth in
Brazil were my first year PhD students
and Matt Patrick and Erin were
undergrads they've all gone on to now to
med school and grad school so when Beth
sat down at our spinning disk confocal
the first time she ever sat down at this
microscope in our lab and she was
imaging gfp-tagged 3 and she saw that
tack 3 was accumulating at the tips of
these microtubules and growth comes here
at the bottom there's this montage of a
microtubule over time you could see the
TAC 3 GFP in labeling the end and this
plus end localization was not
fifteen neurons other cell types also
showed the Plus on localization so in
the bottom you could see these please
read polymers those are microtubules
with the green puncta at the tips of
them that's tack 3 and this was the
first evidence in a vertebrate system
that Caffrey was could function as a
plus I'm tracking protein again movies
of this are you can find on my labs
website now we noticed that the tag free
localization on the end of the
microtubule really looked like a
thumbtack and this was in contrast to
many known plus tips at the time which
had a comment with a long decay and that
led us to wonder well where exactly is
tack 3 on the end of the microtubule so
what I haven't mentioned yet is that the
plus end is home to lots of different
plus tips and they don't all bind to the
plus end by the same mechanism for
example X map to 15 which I mentioned is
at the distal most tip it was thought
that it was the only one out there so
that it's adding on new tubulin dimers
where is eveyone was about 500
nanometers behind x max to 15 in class
which is another plus tip overlap with
and was further behind eb1 so we wanted
to know where is TAC 3 on the present we
performed high resolution
co-localization analysis and saw that
TAC 3 was in front of eb1
and overlapped with X map to 15 and this
was very exciting for us as a new lab
because at the time no other plus tip
had been shown to localize at the
discipline OHS tip when X map to 15 and
it suggested that perhaps TAC 3 was
functioning with X map to 15 to promote
microtubule polymerization to address
this question we wanted to analyze
microtubule dynamics when factory was
manipulated and in my lab the way that
we assess microtubule dynamics is by
using a software package which was
dissolved in the de Newser lab where I
did one of my postdocs and the software
package automatically detects
some quantifies plusted behavior in a
time series it the texts of comics as
these blue dots links them into
trajectories in these red lines and then
extracts a series of quantitative
parameters that quantify describe
microtubule behaviors and using the
software package we found that knocking
down TAC 3 leads to a small but
significant reduction in the vote in the
velocity of microtubule growth whereas
over expressing TAC 3 leads to an
increase in the velocity lifetime was
not affected so catastrophe rate of the
microtubules was not affected but the
polymerization velocity was and this
leads us to the obvious question of how
is tax reinfecting microtubule
polymerization and this is the PhD
thesis project of my grad student
garrett cammarata and he has the help of
some undergrads Ben Quinn and Helen and
they've been asking a series of
questions including first of all is tack
3 recruiting X amount to 15 a plus n so
I'm not going to show you the data but
it the answer is yes tack 3 is indeed
contributing to estimate 215 recruitment
to the plus ends and that's one of the
ways that it's modulating polymerization
dynamics but not the only way so we also
want to know is it promoting xml 215
polymerase activity perhaps by binding
to it that might promote this activity
also we're curious if Caffrey might have
an X I'm up to 15 independent role and
finally we want to explore whether tack
one and tack two also play a role in
regulating microtubule dynamics when we
started studying tack 3 very little was
known about tack 1 and tacked to and
wanted to explore those as well
so first together the question of
whether taquerias directly promoting
polymerization as well as whether it's
contributing to X naught to stream
polymerase activity Garrett has set up
in our lab in vitro microtubule
reconstitution assays of purified
proteins and what he's found thus far is
a tack 3 alone in incubations with
tubulin preps leads to an increase in
the mic
elongation rate and this suggests that
factory might be directly promoting
polymerization but we still have some
controls to run these studies are still
quite preliminary but we're looking
forward to seeing what the repeat
experiments show us in the future
additionally I mentioned there these
other tack members tack one intact - and
when we started working on TAC 3 at the
time in the literature it was stated
that Venezuela's only has one tack
member and in fact was the only
vertebrate model system that only has
one tack member but I again had a
feeling that this was not correct when I
went back and looked at the literature
there are papers that said this cited
previous papers that went back quite a
few number of years even before there
was the Xenopus laevis genome known and
so i decided to look at the current
genome when i found indeed that tack 1
and tacked to have been annotated in
zenefits so i thought this would be
great undergrad projects where we would
clone these genes and then look to see
where they localized in the cell and
again very little was known about the
functions of tack 1 intact - in any
system and so these would be really
important insights to understand the
tack field what we found first is that
tack 1 indeed can act as a + tip just
like tack 3 and that tattoo can act as a
+ tip as well and just like tack 3
manipulating tack 1 intact - did lead to
changes in microtubule dynamics and the
variety of parameters now we wanted to
know whether there was redundancy or
compensation among these tack members
and so we started by looking at using an
in situ hybridization to see where these
tack members were were expressed what we
found is that tack 3 was particularly
expressed in the nervous system in the
neural tube if you look at panel L here
there's a box around the neural tube
localization as well as these these
arrowheads point to the fringe of arches
where neural crest cells are moving down
to populate the face whereas tack 1 and
tattoo they didn't
have that neural neural tube and
craniofacial neural crest cells
localization for their expression
patterns but they were highly enriched
in the somites
and in other certain areas of the brain
including the mandibular nerve so my lab
is currently in the process of exploring
the unique and collective functions of
these tack proteins during development
and and in regulating microtubule
dynamics so now that I've spoken about
the functions of these tacks family
members in terms of regulating and
promoting microtubule dynamics I'm going
to talk about how they're playing a role
in axon guidance this has been the
project of my PhD student Persia were
done and she's had the help of two
talented undergrads Ben and Eric and
what we found is that overexpressing
tack 3 and then plating these neurons
and culturing them to see how they grow
over expression of tack 3 leads to
longer axons and what Bruce found
through time-lapse imaging was that the
longer axons were not due to faster
outgrowth velocity and in fact there was
actually a mild reduction in outgrowth
velocity but instead these axons they
hoped they had a clear reduction in the
retraction rate so under normal
situations control axons will
spontaneously retract at a certain
frequency because axons are they are
subjected to a number of actin mice and
contrast left forces within the axon
itself but with chapter II over
expression this retraction rate that was
spontaneous was almost cut in half and
so these axons would grow more
persistently over time so after a day of
growing the axons would end up being
longer we wanted to know if this change
in persistence could reflect how axons
might respond to guidance cues when we
bath apply sweat which is a
traditionally repellent guidance cue
most control axons more than sixty
percent of them will immediately
retract in response to this repellent
cue but when tack tree is overexpressed
only 10% of the axons will retract and
this again shows that tack tree
overexpression desensitizes the axons to
repellent forces now we know that slit
is it as soluble cue that the growth
cone encounters and somehow tack 3 is
mediating the growth cone response to
flit so one question is well how is it
doing that it's already known that slit
binds to a receptor called Robo on
growth cones and Robo leads to the
activation of a tyrosine kinase called
Abelson tyrosine kinase an able could
potentially phosphorylate tack 3 and
perhaps change its function
- then mediate its response in the
growth cone we wanted to test this and
so our collaborators at University of
Vermont did some kinase assays and they
found that when able is present with TAC
3 TAC 3 has a phosphorylated tyrosine
residue on this right column here that
is not present when TAC 3 is there
without Abelson tyrosine kinase so
somehow the presence of Abell is a
leading tackler to be phosphorylated we
don't know yet if it's direct but we do
know that Tacony is phosphorylated in
response to abel and that that may lead
to changes in how terry modulates
microtubule dynamics and sober zu is in
the process of making mutants of these
of the tyrosine residue to see how that
changes tack threes functions to
regulate microtubule dynamics and in a
growth cone behaviour so our model for
tax refund during axon guidance is that
in the growth cone maybe on one side of
the growth cone you could have a
repellant guidance cue and that would
lead to TAC 3 four lane gin at a certain
site and then TAC 3 would not recruit X
map to 15 to the plus ends so the
microtubules on that side of the growth
cone would be unstable but on the other
side of the growth cone TAC 3 would
recruit
2:15 to the microtubule plus ends the
microtubules would be able to grow and
then the growth come to turn in that
direction
but in the case of overexpression of
tack 3 there is so much factory
overloading the system the tackler will
bind to the plus ends even when they're
not supposed to and then promote extra 5
to 15 localization the plus ends and
microtubule polymerization and so even
though repellent cues are present tack 3
is the growth cone is desensitized to
that and so you'll have accent outgrowth
and sober she was currently in the
process of testing this model in more
detail now at this point I want to
switch gears and talk a little bit about
X map 215 function and growth cones I
told you that it's the classic
microjoule polymerase and so you'd
predict that more xMAP 215 function
would lead to faster microtubule
polymerization and reducing X naught to
15 function will lead to slower
microtubule polymerization
now I actually studied XML 215 a little
bit during my postdoc but when I knocked
it down the plan had been to knock it
down and see a slower polymerization and
then look to see how X about 215 was
spatially regulated in the growth cone
but during my postdoc work when I
knocked X map 215 down I did not find
that microtubule plus ends were slower
and actually the microtubules themselves
were moving in some patterns that were
not expected and because it was a little
bit confusing at the time I decided to
put that project on the backburner as I
started my lab and focus on TAC 3 which
had more of an unexpected phenotype when
I knocked it down but then I knew I
wanted to eventually get back to XML 215
because I could tell that something was
really interesting about XML 215 in
growth comes but it might have a novel
function that had not been previously
explored and so a year ago I had a
postdoc join my lab paulus later and she
had two undergrads working with her
Annika
Alley and they decided to explore extra
up to 13 function and growth comes the
first thing the Paula noticed when she
knocked down XM up to 15 and stained it
for just action microtubules she saw
that the X map to 15 growth cones were
larger than control growth counts you
could see that beat the entire growth
cone area was larger as well as these
philiponius shown in green were longer
as well and these two phenotypes could
be rescued by adding back XML to 15 mRNA
showing that this phenotypes were
specific to XM up to 15 knockdown now
this green this is actin and so what
this data suggests is that XM up to 15
is somehow perhaps indirectly affecting
f-actin but the question is how now here
is a movie showing X map to 15 GFP and
you can see that it's bound to the plus
and it's enriched at the plus ends and
it's also along the microtubule lattice
but it's not obviously enriched in the
f-actin networks in the periphery of the
growth come however these microtubules
that you see are actually growing along
F actin bundles and in order for the
microtubules to grow along the bundles
they have to be coupled in some way to
them however f-actin undergoes
retrograde flow continuously and if the
flow if the flow is couples of
microtubules completely the microtubules
will loop and will not be able to go
into the periphery and so we wonder if X
map to 15 might somehow be regulating
frequent transient couplings from the
f-actin so what paola did is she looked
at microtubules and she used super
resolution microscopy to carefully
quantify the behavior in the
localization of these microtubules
within the growth comp referee well she
found is it in control situations
almost all microtubules are growing
along F actin bundles but you
the xMAP 215 knockdown condition a
significant proportion of microtubules
shown are growing are going off track
you can see there with the arrow heads
here that those microtubules are not
along a faction bundles and again this
could be rescued by adding back xml to
15m RNA and so not only are there more
microtubules there off roading that are
not on the f action tracts but the
penetration of these microtubules into
the peripheral domain of the growth cone
is also increased with XM up to 15
knocked down and so right now Pella is
in the process of deciphering the
mechanistic function by which X map to
15 can couple microtubules and F action
we're very excited to do what this work
shows us in the future
so now I'm going to focus on these newer
projects in my lab on cell migration and
other disorders neural crest cells are a
multipotent migratory embryonic cell
type that they first derived from the
neural tube and then they undergo an
epithelial to mesenchymal transition to
then migrate in very characteristic
patterns to become cranial facial
structures heart tissue skeletal tissue
different muscles and peripheral neurons
and the work in my lab that has been
focused on neural crest cells has been
spearheaded by my PhD student Beth Behrs
now because these neural crest cells
undergo an epithelial to mesenchymal
transition and metastatic cancer cells
also are thought to undergo a epithelial
to mesenchymal transition I was able to
convince the American Cancer Society to
fund my labs work in investigating
microtubule regulators and how they
might be playing a role in neural crest
migration as a model for general cell
motility now we became interested in
neural crest cells when Beth was sitting
at the confocal imaging gfp-tagged 3 and
she was the person that first saw this
plus sound localization you could see
locally the GFP carry is located on
these where the arrow heads pointing
these at the end of these microtubule
but she also saw that in certain
populations of cells such as neural
crest cells gfp-tagged 3 was highly
enriched at the leading edge surrounding
focal adhesion structures now we since
have come to the conclusion that we
think that this localization might be
partially an artifact due to exhaustion
as' expression however it led us in the
direction of looking at neural crest
cells and how they might be playing how
attacked we might be playing a role in
their migration so the first question we
want to know is well is tack 3 expressed
in neural crest cells when we did an in
situ hybridization for tack 3 we found
that indeed tack 3 was highly expressed
in these craniofacial neural crest cells
these arrowheads are pointing to these
three arches those are the pharyngeal
arches on the side of the face and you
can see in the dark purple that the tack
tree is highly enriched in this location
and when we found is when we knocked
down tack 3 we saw it and then used a
different marker for craniofacial neural
crest cells such as Sox 9 we found that
the morphology of these fringes arches
was quite disrupted including there was
a reduction in the length of these
arches and then when my student Beth
took these cells and cultured them and
analyzed the parameters to cell motility
here on the left you could see an ex
plant that she cultured and then she did
time-lapse imaging to look at the
motility dynamics
she found that tack three knockdown led
to slower motility and tack free over
expression led to faster cells and now
she's in the process of examining focal
adhesion dynamics after tack room
interpolation to see if tack 3 effects
either assembly or disassembly of these
focal adhesions and that would be one
way that a3 contributes to cell
migration
in addition to using neural crest cells
as a general model for investigating
cell migration we are also looking at a
particular disorder called wolf
Hirschorn syndrome and this work has
been spearheaded entirely by an
undergrad with Alli Mills with a big
undergrad team in my lab and they've
also had the support of a senior
scientist in my lab
sang-mook lee and what they've been
doing is investigating the genes
associated with wolf first-run syndrome
so we became interested in this syndrome
when we learned that tack 3 is one of
five genes that are missing one copy in
this genetic disorder the wolf Hirshhorn
syndromes field has spent over a decade
figuring out which genes are associated
with this particular disorder and the
disorder is characterized by various
craniofacial defects including a wider
face heart defect skeletal defects and
other issues of cognitive functioning
but what's interesting is that very
little is known about the embryonic
function of these five genes actually
are far three they know somewhat about
but the other genes they're possible
functions during development had not
been characterized and so we thought
that our system would be a really great
model system to finally investigate how
these genes how the genes how two
proteins encoded by the gene these genes
might be playing a role during will
first-run syndrome onset and we wondered
specifically if wolf or shrine syndrome
might be a neural crest on migration
disorder or if at least that's part of
the contributing factors to the to the
phenotypes and so first we want to know
well are these genes expressed in neural
crest cells on the top left is is a
marker for X twist this is a neural
crest cell marker you can see labels
these fringe of arches as well as around
the eye and what we found is that most
of the genes that are
so stay with Beaufort with wolf
Hirshhorn syndrome WH sc1 whst - let M 1
and TAC 3 have already mentioned are
indeed expressed in neural crest cells
so they're expressed in the right place
at the right time to be playing a role
in neural crest on migration so now what
we've been doing is knocking down these
genes individually and collectively and
looking at possible phenotypes during
development for example when we knock
down WH SC one only on the left side of
the embryo on one side what we found and
then we did an in situ Forex twist again
this is a neural crest on marker we
found is that the craniofacial neural
crest cells do not migrate as far down
as in the control side the control
injected side and one of the wonderful
benefits is using benefits latest is you
can actually knock down just one side of
the embryo so you have this internal
control for normal migration patterns so
this is very obvious that knocking down
WH SC one leads to a fringe of arch
defect but knocking down WH SC 2 does
not so this shows that WH SC one may
play a larger role in the in the
craniofacial defects that these patients
show compared to whst 2 we also find
that when we knock down WH SC one in the
entire embryo the entire tadpole we get
a wider face which is reminiscent of the
human phenotype so we're excited for
this preliminary investigations Ali is
in the process of knocking down all of
the genes and then again collectively
knocking them down to see which which
genes correspond to which phenotypes
that occur in Wolf's Hirschorn syndrome
so now I'm going to spend the last few
minutes of my talk talking about
intellectual disability disorders and
what we've been doing with them and this
is a been part of a really great
collaboration with dr. Santos Giri Rajan
at Penn State and I gave a seminar at
Penn State a couple years ago and
santosh is a human geneticist and he
identifies genes that are associated
with various human intellectual
disability disorders but one of the
issues that these human geneticists have
is once they identify all these
potential genes they don't know which
ones are actually contributing to the
brain development issues and so as we
were talking we realized that my model
system would be a very easy and
inexpensive and efficient way to test
the genes that he's identified so for
example and so this has been spearheaded
by my newest PhD student Michaela in my
lab she has a big undergrad team and
again supported by my senior scientist
now Santosh has identified a number of
different deletions including this one
microdeletion on chromosome 16 and
encompasses in us several different
genes
what Mikhail has been doing is knocking
down these genes individually and then
in combination to see what phenotypes
arise during embryonic development we
want to know which genes are responsible
for the various patient's symptoms what
she found so far is that C 16 or 52
promotes axon outgrowth so on the top
left you can see you knocking it down
leads to shorter axons and this could be
rescued by adding back to C 16 or 50 to
mRNA but knocking down the other genes
has no effect on axon outgrowth so C 16
or 32 nothing is known about this gene
and so this is the first first known
function that is playing some sort of
role in axon outgrowth but Michaela is
not just looking at axon outgrowth but
looking at other parameters as well for
example she's looking at craniofacial
defects she has found that knocking down
pull r3e
uq c RC 2 + + 16 or 50 - also shows
craniofacial defects where CDR - shows
no effects at all and then finally these
patients show microcephaly defects and
so here is a quantification of the
facial with for example and so these
patients have craniofacial have a
microcephaly defects and so we're also
looking at microcephaly in those NFS
embryos and in the tadpoles here what we
can find is at pol r3 a knockdown
on one side of the embryo only leads to
the significantly smaller forebrain area
and we are excited to see I continue
using our strategies to investigate
intellectual disability disorders now
before I conclude I just want to mention
that other members of my lab are
focusing on other projects Quinn and
Jack are setting up CRISPR casts 9:00 in
the Xenakis field people are starting to
use this quite successfully just like in
many other systems and so we'll be using
this as a complementary approach to our
current knockdown strategies my student
Kyle Lawrence has a great collaboration
with the cholesky lab at Yale studying
Abelson tyrosine kinase to function in
growth cones and then finally my
undergrad Jim Zhang Jian is looking for
new embryonic functions for a previously
known micro tubule regulator called
siphon with that I want to make a number
of conclusions first of all I want to
reiterate
zenica syllabus is a fantastic embryonic
cell migration model that tack 3 is a
plus tip that promotes microtubule
polymerization during axon outgrowth and
guidance and that all tack members are
plus tips that affect microtubule
dynamics finally XML 215 can couple
growth cone microtubules with f-actin
TAC 3 promotes a neural crest all
migration TAC 3 may contribute to wolf
Hirschorn syndrome along with other wolf
or cern syndrome candidate genes and my
lab is now using Xenakis to investigate
various intellectual disability
disorders and going forward in the
future my lab will continue exploring
plus tip function during axon guidance
and different types of cell migration in
both normal and pathological conditions
with that i want to acknowledge the
members of my lab i have a really large
group but we are organized in teams and
it's been very productive so far I've
had great alumni that are now on to grad
school and med school and put in other
places I've been fortunate with having a
great team of collaborators and I've
also been fortunate with acquiring
funding I thank you for your attention
and I'm happy to answer any questions
you might have
thank you
dr. Larry and thank you for that
informative presentation and your
dynamics research team we will now start
the live Q&A portion of this webinar if
you have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on that
green Q&A button at the lower left of
your presentation window type your
questions into that box that appear on
the screen and click that Sun button
well answer as many questions as we have
time for so let's get started with our
audience members our first question
today is you are focusing on the
functions of tack 3 in this presentation
are there other tack family members that
function similarly yeah that's a great
question I did I briefly mentioned tack
one and tack - but I didn't have a
chance to talk about their particular
functions so it's really interesting as
I mentioned they both function as plus
tips
but they function in different ways so
tack one is actually slightly behind
tack 3 on the plus end and why it's
slightly behind it and what it's doing
there is still unclear tack 2 on the
other hand is actually at the tip with
tack 3 and so we're trying to understand
you know what these different functions
that they mediate could be so tack one
is as I said it slightly behind tack 3
and yet when you knock it down it has
the same function of tacky so knocking
tack one down leads to slower
microtubule polymerization when you
knocked a Quan and tack and tack three
down together there suddenly is a
microtubule catastrophy know type so
it's clear that there are both unique
and redundant functions of these tack
members tack two on the other hand when
we knock it down we do not see slow or
microtubule growth in fact in some cases
we see faster microtubules so we still
need to dissect which parts of the
proteins are functioning in various
capacities and regulated microtubule
dynamics but we you know we hope to make
some new insights in the future there's
a lot known about TAC three there's you
know
a handful of papers about tack 1 and
there's almost nothing known about
tattoo and so we look forward to making
these new insights as we go forward
thank you
we have audience members tuning in from
several countries today here's our next
question coming in does xMAP to15
also play a role in axon guidance that's
a great question so I talked about its
role perhaps coupling microchip is
enough acting but I didn't talk at all
about what it's doing in terms of
guiding the growth count so what I found
is that knocking down X map to 15 also
leads to shorter axons just like
knocking down tack 3 but as I said we
don't see the same microtubule effects
what I haven't done yet my lab has not
challenged the growth cone with guidance
views to then see if X map mediates the
response to those cues I would predict
that it does especially if it's involved
in coupling X microtubules with f-actin
because that coupling is gonna be really
important as I mentioned for whether the
growth cone moves in one direction
versus another but we still have to do
those assays we have to do similar I
think to what we what I showed where we
apply various cues and see if if X
amount to 15 manipulation changes the
response we also need to challenge the
growth cone with some asymmetric cues
and see if that if growth cone responses
are different on when X map is
manipulated so we are actively working
on those we have an ro1 to fund that
work and we hope to find out in the near
future
FX map 215 is indeed mediating axon guys
I would predict that it is but we have
to test and see thank you dr. Lowry we
have time for one more question from our
audience can you talk a little more
about the wolf Hirshhorn syndrome and
the role that pack 3 might play in that
disorder yeah definitely so wolf horan
syndrome has been characterized for over
a decade and again the the geneticists
have been very carefully focused on what
specific genes of these five genes
are needed to be missing but again
they're only missing one copy to lead
through the various human phenotype and
you know when I read about these
phenotypes there's two craniofacial
defects and heart defects and skeletal
defects it neural crest cells is a ring
about and so I recently published a
review with one of my students proposing
the idea that will first Horn syndrome
might be a neural crest on migration
disorder and in terms of what tack three
could be doing within that within the
onset of this disorder since TAC three
is highly expressed in these neural
crest cells it's quite possible that
knocking down tack 3 leads to changes in
neural crest cell migration that then
result in these various defects however
I have to point out that tack 3 is also
required for cell division so we need to
do some more careful studies to see if
if so migration or cell proliferation
are affected and so we look forward to
doing that in the future I have a March
of Dimes grant as well as the National
Institute of dental and craniofacial
research grant to fund this work and
both of these grants were one of the
grants of the pilot grant so we're still
just you know getting our feet wet in
terms of dissecting the functions of
these genes in assist order but I
anticipate we'll be making some really
important insights as we move forward
thank you dr. Larry did you have any
closing remarks you wanted to provide
the audience members reported closed no
it's been a pleasure presenting my work
to it to all of you and I encourage you
to check out my my lab website if you
just search Lowry Lab at Boston College
I have all of the publication's of my
lab of the last of four years and and
links to all of them and to the movies
as well and I know many of the movies
can do the play on this presentation and
I encourage you to contact me if you
have any further questions I'm happy to
help you out dr. Barr thank you so much
for your presentation and also the
important work that the Lowry research
team is doing in that lab I also like to
thank lab reach for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will
available for on-demand viewing through
December 2017 so receive an email from
lab roots letting you know when the
webcast will be available for replay
please share that announcement with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us and we hope to see you
again soon bye bye